dr nash has been helping people all
across the valley with their weight loss
journeys
today we look at some of her amazing
clients and their results
dr nash always great to have you on the
show and this is one of my favorite
shows
we talk about transformations because
you've been transforming lives
all across the valley and i want to
start with someone very special
and that special person is you and your
transformation let's talk about the
things you've done
with your own body yeah so i'm somebody
that started gaining weight when i was
eight years old and between
eight years old in about 2009 when i
learned the information that i shared
with my clients i'd been on about 36
different types of diets and they would
just never work either the weight loss
was slow or the weight would come back
and once i found out about issues under
the surface that actually
sabotaged the weight loss that's when i
was able to turn it around i was able to
lose 80 pounds
i love it you've kept the weight off you
look you look beautiful we're going to
talk about someone who i haven't seen
before
we're going to talk about kimberly let's
take a look at kimberly's transformation
17 and a half pounds 26 and a half
inches
the evil back fat is gone thanks dr nash
what a transformation the thing that
jumps out to me as she talks about it
the uh no more back fat that stubborn
fat is gone
right so women in particular tend to
notice that they get this weight in the
trunk
area the upper lower belly the back the
butt and for whatever reason it's
difficult to shift it they might see
weight loss in other areas but that area
is stubborn
that usually means that there's damage
something that's keeping the body fat
there
and that was the case with kimberly she
had a lot of inflammation we were able
to turn it around
and the midsection just dropped she got
26 and a half inches in just 30 days
unbelievable and speaking of
unbelievable everybody get ready
let's take a look at laura when i
started with dr nash i weighed over 300
pounds and i was pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds
and i no longer have that pre-diabetic
threat so laura was 58 years old and
laura was also thoroughly convinced that
it was menopause
she did have a hormone problem but it
actually was not
menopause it was her dietary hormone so
when we were able to turn that around
and correct it
she lost a person like she became half
the woman
physically and double the woman mentally
that she
yeah amazing stuff that you're doing
everyone take a look at meredith we're
looking at meredith's photos right here
she lost a total of 30 pounds
she's my more recent example because
this is somebody that came to me during
the quarantine so she's seeing weight
gain as a result of the current
restrictions
so we were able to correct her virtually
all she did was walking in terms of
exercise because everything was closed
and bam
not only 30 pounds off but that again
that whole
midsection area that's that stubborn
belly fat
and every week you got a special what do
you have for us this week i do so
normally
if you come into my office it would be
97 to do the evaluation
because we are doing it on tv here with
jc all you got to do is mention that you
saw me on las vegas now
go online we have 10 spots available but
only 10
but they're 9.97 we'll be able to do the
entire evaluation completely online to
keep you safe
and it'll give me the opportunity to
help find out what's wrong
and help you turn it around so you lose
the weight for good there's more las
vegas now just ahead
we will be